ariana has a hell of a voice and she
is the sweetest nicest person and
it's a pleasure to work with her because
everything that happens to her is so
exciting
well apparently it hasn't always been a
pleasure working with ariana grande
our longtime manager scooter braun is
opening up about the time
she fired him at the end of the day
i just sort of have to focus know my
truth work hard be nice to everyone you
meet and just
not fight back i try to create and
maintain but sometimes it's very hard
speaking at fast companies innovation
festival this week scooter revealed the
break free singer let him go
in 2016 hinting it was all due to her
boyfriend at the time
quote i could have said a lot of stuff
and in fact my team
wanted me to they were like never take
her back
but i just said let's stay quiet and let
our truth be our actions
adding when boyfriends leave she starts
to see the light on some stuff
[Music]
obviously scooter took ariana back on as
a client and he says the whole thing
actually made him a better manager quote
i had never been fired before
it made me know that as much as you give
to people in a service business
you can never expect anyone to
reciprocate
you have to do it for the right reasons
and if you get screwed over in the end
so be it she needed to do you know what
was right
and work hard and my work will speak for
itself now it's unclear who the quote
boyfriend was as the timing falls
somewhere between ariana's relationships
with big sean
and mac miller who died unexpectedly at
the age of 26
this september which has obviously hit
ariana hard
she split from fiance pete davidson
weeks later and
has pulled out of some work as of late
you saw your invite someone i'm very
close to was supposed to come sing for
you today
and because of things that she's going
through she couldn't be here today and
while i was frustrated being the manager
my wife being who she always is just
looked at me and she goes she needs this
time
you